oh yeah uh welcome everyone
to uh this excellent rue tenefa
facility it's quite nice to have a
change of venue for the waimakariri
water zone
meeting i think uh thank you for
facilitating that it'd be nice to
come here more often next year possibly
um so welcome all and
mr ruben could you start
microphone uh
[Applause]
okay so welcome along everyone again i'm
uh michael blackwell i'm the current
chair
and community member for the zone so
i'll
pass off to my left here murray if you
could introduce yourself and then just
uh
do a roll call and story everyone murray
griffin facilitator
for this lovely committee erin harvey
community members
council clinton bank leader
angus environment science
[Applause]
okay
thank you call for apologies please
henderson
anybody else that's probably it i think
i have a mover and a seconder for that
apology
just on a note on that did i so you got
married in between this meeting and the
last meeting
congratulations to canvas
congratulations commiserations
all right um
we are recording still to
put this on youtube yes
so it's a bit tricky we haven't got
microphones but please speak
as clearly as possible
alrighty 1.4 registrations of interest
is there any change
[Applause]
[Music]
rebuilding that strong team
thank you i'll just note those in real
time any others there
i could possibly delete myself as
treasurer for the north carolina pay
target association i don't seem to need
me anymore
[Applause]
would you like me to yeah i think we're
going to bring that one up to date
thank you alrighty
anything else there folks item two
opportunity for the public to speak
michael
[Applause]
mike i've just put your pin drive just
up there next to that
[Applause]
yes
um
[Applause]
good news today
this we've got the beach grove creek on
the suburban look like two years ago
what it looks like today which is the
last
there's actually quite a few sparrows
speeding on the
consequence here on the ground
i'm not sure what might have happened is
yeah usually with
subdivisions the stormwater assets are
get uh are invested with the council
after a certain period of time
it could be that this has been coming
through the council i'm not sure
what um that has happened or
management or whether it's the
subdivision the developer is
they're still maintaining it is making
it a different way
that's right
same scenario comes down through the
grass here and down into the drain
around the corner
it looks nice and healthy well
elementary right there
there's probably about eight to nine
ducks here and on there
you can see the wheatgrass here in the
bottom
i've given the way i will spray
now this is the last king that i showed
you last month
and i'll show you can feather
right from
road right down to where it comes into
the junction on the south front
of the south pole
there's not a bit of weed in it i never
saw a fish in it at all
all these streams and brains and creeks
i've been showing how they all look the
same
[Music]
there's some sort of chemicals
you can see the weed on the right inside
the
now the weed downstream from this
junction wherever there's quiet water
it's all covered in brown algae the
nutrients running out of the can
creating the help we can grow
river two years ago
left alone
you know there's a bit of fish right
there and nothing what should be there
on the right hand side there you can see
a black tree's been sprayed right at the
top
now this is in the sticks river see the
pole in the middle on the right hand
side that's the capitoli stream right
here notice there's no weed there it's
all brown and muddy
i'm sorry for the clear the top of the
tree here it makes it hard we see the
wheat but it's all weed on the other
side
of the wheat one side's over the other
side it's not
the capital stream runs for about four
and a half k's there's actually no weed
in the whole thing
i want to know why
and there's really no light
now last month they're going about the
ocean airport
nothing to do with the foam on the beach
that's just absolute rubbish
it's only here on an onshore breeze this
is what it can be like
whenever there's an onshore breath i can
take you down and show you samples of it
every several times sometimes it's not
much you can still see it that's where
it's bad
i've got days towards clear day
next one please
two weeks ago and no deep birds
rot now be still there they are
de-slugging some of it
they haven't got enough money to do it
all and it's
heaps and each of the bed depending on
the weather
the boxes are still going to be there
coming up with a long-term plan in about
12 months
are you talking 15 20 years they're
still going to kill our bootleg
this is not acceptable not to any reason
my advantage
did
we can do something about this you can
see it on this planet's prosthetic
this is the ecan's fault in the
government
and the council this is not acceptable
in new zealand
you shouldn't have to put up with it
[Applause]
prices city council the town you've got
on top of it
isn't public
because that's full of elements it's
growing more elderly today
as it matures at times
that's how we get watching them in the
wild we've got vegetation normally
and it doesn't care and alone this is
this is what our gut population used to
be like in classrooms
this is not actually any kind would but
this is what it used to be like before
they were killed
absolutely
oh they can't do the job look after the
environmental citizens of the old
academy
in the whole of new zealand where is
that
down in the caribbean
any questions
[Applause]
i just wanted to ask um perhaps
to sophie have there been any outbreaks
of
um botulism at the ponds or anywhere in
our
district at the moment
[Music]
i have asked how i would even keep an
eye out so the ones who are particularly
at the bombs and we'll look at the
contractors like the social
morphological contractors answering
regular checks
it is likely a hot summer yes so
firebreast thank you so
so to counter that risk and possibly
through you sandra
what's the ability of the council
operators to maintain
the water level at a higher level in the
sewage process
yeah so which is notification i've had
from the indiana patients and who's our
wastewater engineer is that
we um usually have the same level of
water it's just how fast the water is
going through so we've got a weird
it's just about so one a couple years
ago we did lower the water level and
some of the times
these slides and that in fact it was a
bad outbreak that year so we won't do
that again in the summertime
but usually it's the same level it just
takes you know 100 days rather than
30 days to go and work its way through
summertime because you've got more
inspiration so we
can't make the level higher there's
already an empty level
it's just about you know were flushed
through
but that area is over allocated from
groundwater and you can imagine the
outcry we see
there put a whole beautiful ground water
into place
so in terms of how to
get more water in it's true it's not
something you've got an idea
but but as a preventative measure
maintaining that
level as high as possible that's our
standard it would have to be
something we'd actually have to decide
to do something sludging or some work
since other side
to decrease that people and we're not
that's part of it maybe it watches a
major plan to not do that
christchurch
so the last few years have also been
it's been low on my micro district
council
and so it could just be environmental
faces there's quite a few quite a few
things and it could also be that
while the area can trigger it generally
this is probably more environmental
factors that have just been
we are causing it in any way to stop us
you heard the floating as
much as possible your oxygen in the
water
though trying to run about or anything
she's going to run itself
our council has received a review from
the spca they had a conference up in
auckland last year about age botulism
and they reviewed our management plan as
institutions which were
looking at a couple of those but some
things are
like a health and safety risk for
contractors to try and go out and rescue
birds and so
the wheatland area is not feasible
in many cases because they're so far out
yeah
yes so yeah we are trying to
do what we can from that review kind of
that's a
really basic question because i don't
have familiarity with the situation
with it within that management plan
is there any know provision for keeping
the birds away from
food secures or selects to say you know
go find somewhere that's not the way to
look
yeah so that's something that
people using um who've tried to tear
into the past
not but if you're watching but for other
reasons and
they got used to it straight away and
it's a common thing
yeah it's very difficult to find
something to keep birds away
constantly so you might have something
that you just deploy in a short
time and you know just take it with you
because you can do
cannons like a sound like um
make a voice every 10 minutes and then
in terms of in the seed foam i think
adrian might know a bit more about it
how it was very difficult to collect a
sufficient amount of it for testing
and getting at the right time
you're trying to tell me
our next step would be in that respect
given that we've been given this advice
and the council
i i could probably back that up i wasn't
at the meeting with the seafoam
discussion come up but
not that you probably tell but i surfed
every day for maybe tweaked my first 20
years or my
you know teenage years yeah and there
was seafoam all through those years and
that was obviously
25 years before the sewerage airport so
was it the yucky looking
recently that had similar looking foam
in it as well broken up sort of like
speckles
so where did you take that photo yeah
but it looked quite
you
but maybe we need to speak to some of
the south life savers
anyway thanks for being with us
any more questions michael uh i'm
going to come back to your first two
photos um and it's sort of
nice to see the change and outcome from
a change in management practice so
thanks for highlighting that
we're all trying to take steps in the
right direction and that's a good
example of it
i've got an email from pete i'm not
going to go into it
well feel free to bring it up at the
last meeting of the year
if you'd like to cool
thank you
[Applause]
item three we have uh quarterly updates
from sophie
and murray
and cake
on the side okay
uh
[Applause]
so um we have an emoji sign between
ecam staff and wd dc staff
for uh implementation of the zipper so
that's a great success to find
him in the bag um
kaiapoi and zandawara townships we are
meeting econ staff
on site and we're going to talk about
the monitoring program and how that's
going to work so it's almost fair
same with the drainage and maintenance
among works consent also imagine for
several draft conditions being tweaked
here and there but that might be your
day now
there's a question around strawberry
education
so we do still have some funding in the
budget full story education
hopefully for our school program next
year i still can't confirm what exactly
until
our education program that that part the
stormwater education is
packaged in with the rest of our
biodiversity
and cultural conservation and other
kinds of education
and whether that um yeah it hasn't been
there has been a final decision yet
about whether it's going to be in-house
or contract
but it is going to happen next year um
[Music]
we kate and i carried out some stock
water based surveys
to inform ourselves and also it's really
good to know what was
those from what i understand i was
talking to them
some anecdotal evidence that herbicide
spray people are spraying their braces
too much in some places and that's
basically all you can find is freshwater
deep freshwater muscle shells or
dead snail shells so that's something
that i will be working on for education
in this coming year there is a note that
the macintosh
drain site where i was planning to do
something this morning planting that's
now going to be
superseded by the sugary project of our
council the 18 million
project that's going to have a big
wetland area so in a way we're just
upgrading
and good news there and yeah the last
point was the private wells with the
nitrate study that
boxes went up but we could have to go
and i think most of the stuff to come
back in
did you want to have anything married
um i can probably i mean just
to touch on some of the key points of
behavior and then
marco here to talk in terms of science
and operations
if you've got um obviously from the
science point of view that thank you for
an overwhelming focus um and a priority
that will carry through to december and
into the new year
um so yeah as the report highlights that
continues to be
a sustained point of focus for the team
um yeah i think that
what amber's provided here in terms of
his support terms of district council in
terms of that
second pilot study the nitrate
monitoring
if there's quite significance and
yeah the infiltration trial is carrying
on which is something that was
initiated during the zipper development
phase
um and the other thing yeah that gets
that time to turn into a draft
model user guide for the grandmother
model two is being fairly significant
for the hearing so it took you to
amber today uh
what in terms of the hearings process
and what um
got circulated to you all by way of a
report that's coming through
and being driven by the hearing process
uh
in the early year she'll put together
a um a summary documentary
the reports that are being developed
through the humanist process that are
the end
of that point public if they'll be on
the planet seven website
just in terms of of making it accessible
to you as a committee and to the wider
public in terms of where are those
reports
so given that they're located in slight
location so she's going to
pull that together and provide a
deliberate message
and then follow through on the march as
well as the process to go through but
certainly just
to highlight to you know some of the
technical reporting that's being
required through the
process as well so that's something that
we can expect in the first
couple of meetings of next year
so from surface water well you know
adrian if you want to
tell me anything yeah
the data that you talked about on page
we that first paragraph under
groundwater team when we
look at the monitoring of the nitrate
concentration in the silver stream
springs where is that data and can we
have copies of it
direction of channel nitrate limits for
streams monitoring
well i'll have to follow up on that in
terms of um
i assume that's not planned change seven
generated so in which case
in terms of the the ongoing monthly
baseline
right track concentrations and services
[Music]
i'm not exactly sure of the location of
that deep well
um what immediately came to mind was
when we were
developing the zipper of the ones that
were put on the other side of the wanaka
and whether there's that's an additional
deep well on that side
where the well is on those two points
thank you
[Applause]
so from a surface work point of view um
you've got the salinas data
in the cargo river just besides this
building
and adrian updated on that
[Applause]
lakes was
another presentation item for the
committee as well is that sophie and
eddie provided looking at the management
of those lakes and the
particular nature of this is
fake lakes but artificial likes that
technically um so yeah
i guess you've had some background too
there and similarly pegasus
um adrian's been attending some of this
are interested to see what level of
responsibility they have
so i don't know if there's anything that
jared
[Applause]
at the moment
uh using their consultants to look at
options um so there
is costing of
what trial solutions might look like so
we've had good positive
conversations with temple and group and
they actually extended
our technical meeting an invitation to
the residence
group who attended which i thought was
great from that transparency
so we've got some positive signs
so the other items that are there on the
surface
water you've got um as we touched on the
workshop session
shot session um looking at the elbow
blooms
and following up as adrian provided a
briefing
early meetings an earlier meeting around
the
research and looking at the nature of
those booms
um and particularly what is being
identified as
perhaps a relationship to groundwater
coming to surface as well so that's
probably something that
could potentially be part of future
research in that
we maintain an ongoing liaison with the
researchers to
illustrate to them that we're still very
interested in wanting to
is something that we've been focused on
in the last while too and and
that's just noting that we um had
followed up on the the nega sites
and fish passage on those key strings
um and
uh this one going into fixing your
monitoring on those structures so
um so that's been all going to focus
over the last
is something that adrian will speak to
at this meeting
um in terms of uh in the silver stream
and i think in the color boys
[Applause]
as well so yeah are there any questions
around that science
i was just going to ask um on the kafka
river
um
[Applause]
are you more specific about summer when
would you hope to get it
well i've got i've got a presentation
lately with the agenda and um
and so what i run through with that is
is um
it'll be it'll certainly yes it won't be
before
there's a number of uh positive
attributes of putting together
there's a few hold ups as well of time
to design it so it goes in and it works
well
we're also having to recruit a staff
member that we lost as well that would
be the normal person that would be
installing this but
um it's not going to happen immediately
but certainly there's no impediments to
getting it in later this summer i would
imagine probably
more likely to be around like january
february at the stage
cool thank you
okay um operations um
i don't know if andrew or marco want to
switch to this or
maybe just walk
[Applause]
river revival stays in there is a it's
an ongoing piece of
work over the over the top of what we're
doing with the rakahuri being a focus
for that program
being established
as you'll see there we have got some
works comments on
three wetland weed projects under three
minutes steps which um the committee
um supported earlier in the year
as noted before i think that yeah the
monthly area
that um is being worked on with um
wvc dock and brick waters trust is a
collaborative effort
let's go and protect that area
and we've as we've touched in earlier in
the year the new floodgate at taranaki
stream so
um yes that's not a significant
achievement in terms of that
catchment
so these next items
can someone clarify
what what apparently has happened
because the floodgate is thin
the um area is now
high and dry so what are the ongoing
remedial work or what what is going to
happen to that because
repairing that floodgate has stopped the
water coming up
where it flooded and now the enum is
falling inside it is no longer
so what is happening about
fish passage and in the life of the nps
which takes precedence here the health
of that waterway
and the fish life or the
reduction of flooding and
gone or has it just moved somewhere else
i think there's a complicated situation
going on there and
it'll be really interesting to follow it
over over the next year or two because
it's been a very very dry year so we're
trying to disentangle whether that
low water levels above the floodgates
and in the waikoku strip and the waikoku
sort of area
as a result of more efficient of the
efficient ceiling
of the floodgate or whether it's um
or whether it's sort of regionally low
ground water levels for given the very
dry year we've had
and it's really hard to disentangle
those two
until we've seen how things behave
further further over time um certainly
there was a lot of concern with us
putting the window in that floodgate to
allow fish
in that it would allow too much water in
and flood that area
now we've been undertaking a trial
recently of keeping that keeping that
window closed to begin with
to establish a sort of baseline process
when we open that window we'll sit we'll
see what the difference is
i suspect it'll make very little
difference in terms of net water flow
in terms of water levels up through
there and it's
it's a very difficult conversation to
have
because um we weren't expecting it to be
so dry
as it was and and certainly talking to
fred brooks the river engineer i think
he was surprised that there's been such
an effect
there and we're both both talking that
it's probably more likely to be a
climate effect we're seeing rome and a
flood game but
there's also it also in terms of those
areas if
if that's going to be a permanent change
in water level that you know
moving upward would find a new spawning
area further up
probably anyway so when are you opening
the
that's a conversation i've got to have
with three books ago so we
we haven't really looked at the water
level data from the recorder that was up
at the
road there but we'll certainly come back
to the next meeting and give you a
clearer strategy on what that is
okay thank you
um
and the environmental impact assessment
was done before the gate went in
i'm not sure that actually so i just
wonder if there is
if the liaison between the ecologists of
both councils and engineers
and local landowners is actually
happening is this a
good example of what happens when
a well-known area in terms of
is
perspective is groundwater levels are
very very very low level at the moment
and i think that's probably having a
much greater effect
than actually the replacing the
floodgates and it's disentangling those
everyone's got an opinion on it
to some extent and i know even after we
first put floodgates in they weren't
sealing as well as we thought they were
and
in many respects we were thinking the
crop they were probably very little of
an advantage
and yet we were seeing that effect of
lower water levels
now i know red rocks have spent a bit of
time trying to get the ceiling better
and things like that
but it's one of those challenges of
trying to disentangle
the actions and the responses
we did have a problem of that we were
anticipating there was going to be a
padlock on the
window it was actually just had a bolt
that people have been playing with and
removing and all sorts of things
so that was another thing so people
don't leave things
[Music]
and working with those farmers
70 outside the middle command area and
50 other independent farms
as well they're requiring consent so
and has also been running dropping
sessions for those farmers as well to
provide
general advice so that's been currently
several months and obviously through the
last quarter
so that i think it continues onwards
those dropping sessions
farms that require the land use consents
have they
are they have a particular size of that
because i know there was
originally a target for the larger farms
so is this
now the target leaders to the smaller
properties
um i couldn't say i don't know if marco
knows the answers
other than that they're outside of the
wool scheme yeah
i think that's still working um from
what i understand it's the next one
okay
yeah the next bullet item is around the
[Music]
up with um with macaroni and
have a look at some of the work he's
doing with farmers
he's also done a session with
the primary industry network group and
taking 25
plus industry people out for a session
which i think was really well received i
certainly
remember attending an earlier meeting
where there was
real demand to to get an opportunity to
have some time with my brain
and work through that i've included to
that end um
uh the flyer and the gender papers i've
studied particularly
having had the opportunity to go and
have a better
position with my friend it was useful
just to include the fly over so you
could have a look at that and just
promote it more widely as well um
and that that engagement's including a
next generation farming group
there's an over and national river care
doc and
the lifestyle group as well so i guess
it's just that
ongoing outreach extension around the
hindu kai
that's what's going on so there's
actually
some additional resources that um
has developed as well which are not to
be really useful too
right yeah i i just included that flyer
to start with but yeah
yeah all right so it's quite a useful
morning
he's a very valuable member of your team
so
on the downside which is somewhat ironic
he was probably
a wee bit quieter than what he normally
was because he had just come out of
hospital having
suffered a kidney infection from
gathering kai that was
from a polluted waterway so there's a
good illustration of the amount of work
we've got to do
but he he touched on one point which i
thought was very valid and that's just
the incremental attitude change he's
starting to see
as he makes his presentations initially
there was a real standoff to this whole
concept but
gradually it's getting traction and
understanding and
and more people in the community are
starting to come on board and i think
that's
that's something we've just got to keep
fostering
to keep him going but i think yeah he's
starting to
um get a better reception from from
some farmers as well so it's great i
think yeah and i think
developing
and those resources may make a
difference
so yeah i think i'm sure it helps too
that you know develops yourselves
going out and getting some exposure
is a good thing as well
building awareness
um following from that two year the
winter crazy campaign
this is noted there and that's
jointly posted by those industry
partners
is another quite important piece of work
um so yeah there's a special
future sessions coming up for that as
well so that's part of the strategy
going into 2021.
um and the session that was them has
caught out over 20 10 days
um and the the other the last item on
that
section two just is that i'm going
catching support
for some of the very good work that's
been initiated by members around this
table as well
so um just noting some of
the work that's involved in the last
quarter
any questions in and around that we want
to add to any of that but
i guess that's just highlighting and
some of the support that goes on from
the start point of view to some of those
initiatives
with landowners in the zone i just
wondered what
um what are you guys up to
actually
that's within dara in quotes um i'll
firstly agree that yes
they're happy to do that obviously it is
in line with what fonterra
ultimately because it isn't done but
yeah
so at this point company of quotes some
are
better here with the others there's a
couple that we're just following up with
making sure because they had other ideas
um of where that money may have been
better but
i guess for what we're trying to achieve
uh it really is about the water quality
aspect
and
but also sort of aside to that
i think going forward to use this as a
model um
using sort of sub-catching degrees and i
know caroline
across the road saltwater creek there is
that was that you
yeah yeah so sort of getting smaller
it might be worth having if we going
forward if we sort of go into little
areas with smaller softwares
that somebody from the zone committee
puts their hand up is that key contact
so
they've actually been very kind um in
the fonterra group we went out initially
to meet and sell the idea
and if we're going forward with that
with that sort of
model that we have perhaps somebody that
puts the hand up
from the design committee that might
want to
sort of come along in the initial
process well i've um spoken to
probably eight or ten funds in the
taranaki waikoku
catchment and they're quite keen to um
one of them
has offered to have the others around
his place to talk about whether they
want to form a group
and i had offered to um you know
help tell them what needed to be done
and
and sort of illustrate what we've done
with the saltwater creek group and if
they want to do the same thing
we can get banking trust and again to
sort of run a similar sort of process
so i had spoken to all the founders i
think well
about two or three weeks ago but it was
just a really busy time for them
especially the dairy guys
and whatnot so we decided well they
decided
um let's just leave it for a few weeks
and so give
them a call a couple of weeks time and
see what i can to
just have that informal gathering to
start off with and then see where that
goes to from there
[Applause]
excellent
thank you i was just going to ask
everybody i mean this is the first time
we've had
this quarterly report in this format and
whether
people had any suggestions about whether
you know this is the way you'd like to
see it
going going forward i mean it's
it's been the best so far in that it's
got quite a bit of
detail with bullet points about what's
happening
in various areas and by various councils
so i just wanted to ask whether
more of this or any suggestions about
how is this the right level of
information i'd like a bit more
information
actually as i said but what about what's
the view from the rest of you about this
style of reporting
every quarter
and as we mentioned in our workshop i
think we as a zone
are very fortunate to have both councils
working so well together
and it's it's meaning more work is
getting done on the ground
so keep it up
[Applause]
further questions here um
so i recommend that we as a zone
committee receive
that quarterly update from the combined
councils
and i have uh move her in a second place
do we have any discussion to follow from
that
i just like to congratulate both
councils on
what is the best to my mind
what is the best example of reporting so
far and
excellent work and keep it up
which we're going to look at all the
hazards that we have in our lives
don what do you need
so for those of you who don't know don
is the senior engineer advisor for wdc
a man of many hats
[Applause]
um
[Music]
uh
foreign
there's
yes
thank you very much good afternoon
everybody
my name is tom yum and i've been asked
to bring up speed
with uh
our information gathering on various
hazards
this is a little bit of a background one
of the main reasons we've been doing
this is as you will be well aware the
proposed plan will be notified
in the coming months about march
and so around about a year ago we turned
our mind as to whether the underlying
information that we had
was of sufficient robustness to support
those policy decisions
that would have been necessary as part
of that process
and the conclusions we came to was in a
number of areas no it wasn't
there had been quite a lot of rework
new information better information
emerging over the last five years or
more
and so with that in mind we've
undertaken
two or three reasonably significant
undertakings in order to better
model and therefore predict some of
these hazards that
we're faced with so this particular
presentation is not around
the policy response at the stage that
will be part and parcel of the actual
district plan and the consultation that
we can place on that
all i'm really going to talk about today
is the actual modeling of
the the hazard so in other words
the scientific data for for women
now what i thought it would be best
doing today is just showing you firstly
where
you can find this information and then
just a little bit walking you through
what it is that you will see so
hopefully we will get to that
it's a bad introduction
you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i can just give a little bit of an
update while we're waiting the main
areas that we
have been modeling uh relate to flooding
the coastal and the flooding has three
elements to it
which we have modeled all three elements
and then prepared hazard maps
which take um the worst of those
instances so they don't add the
instances together they take an either
or
or approach to prepare a map which
shows the extent of where flooding may
occur
if one of these things happens and the
three things in particular that we're
modeling
one we call them localized flooding
which i think is fairly obvious it's
rainfall landing on the land
and running off the land and in
particular
rainfall events what might the impact of
that be
in terms of flooding and obviously we're
looking at you know
the 100 100 year one and 200 year 1 500
year those different types of events
as well as the smaller ones as well the
second of those
issues that we'll be looking at is
actually breakout
and so again you're working very closely
with people
to understand where those breakouts
might occur and what
size they may be and what frequency that
might occur
and then including that in our model
with some degree of underlying wet land
so to speak outside the boundary
previously then this was done 10 years
or so ago
it was assuming dry land outside when
this bridge occurred
which was an easier way to model of
course but not as accurate
in terms of the actual effect but again
equally obviously we wouldn't have
a 500 year event outside the river at
the same time as we had a 500 year
in the river because they are driven by
different catchments
so they actually get different one more
country catchments but it is reasonable
we expect that there would still be a
significant rainfall occurring on the
plains down here
in the asian corridor the third one is a
little bit more difficult to explain
what we did
is we recall the coastal inundation and
effectively what it does is it looks at
about 10 different scenarios
where we are considering a very
high storm event with
a medium-sized river event or vice versa
and it also includes things like sea
level
seatable rise as well as increasing
ground being associated with increasing
groundwater and those sorts of things
so as a result all of that
as a result of all of that we have
firstly those
individual maps that people can go into
and see the effect of
each of those elements and then we've uh
combined them into a flooding hazard map
which we're intending will drive the
the policy response in terms of the
district plan
and we do get on here on the other
showing both of those
other matters that we've considered
for rupture for instance which of course
is again as you'll know
is different from shaking the shaking
may occur throughout our district and is
a factor that is really covered by
building it so the building act will
determine
how strong you need to build your
building anywhere within
zone a or zone b around new zealand
whatever the zone may be that
you know the national international
level has been agreed
the fault rupture is much more localized
and it is aware
where the ground may actually split and
that is
so we know where there are some fault
lines
and we will you know we have again
plotted those and where we know those
fault lines very accurately
we've got quite a narrow band which says
thou shalt not build the fitness where
much
less aware of the position of the top
line
we've got a much fuller bandwidth
actually we're not too sure
so please stay away from this wider area
tsunami
stage we are basing
our tsunami model which you'll see here
today on a lot earlier work
whereas again you may be aware that
christchurch city
have been
looks like we have a success have been
updating their tsunami
modelling far more recently now that
information has just recently emerged
from by
but it hasn't yet made its way into the
plants that we can see
that we'll go and see shortly in front
of us
i
so just to give you the base information
this is our home page
thank you very much this is our home
page on the waimakariri district council
site
and if you go up into have a say here
unfortunately let's talk
and unfortunately we're no longer a
current consultation
so as you'll see when that opens
we will be in previous consultations
[Laughter]
yes
so the tsunami has not yet been updated
in terms of our
hazard mapping but it will be done um
away from this process
uh so you can see here we've got our
live
consultation processes open here and if
you go down to the closed consultation
and you'll see the natural hazards model
in that update
which again if you double click on that
and down here we've got
updated maps and models
so when we go into this you'll see tabs
along the top that we've been referring
to
it's just loading up you'll see a
particular fault rupture
liquid fashion we haven't mentioned yet
effectively the council has made the
decision not
to update its equifax information and
modeling
from what was done back in about 2013
uh and the reason for that is while
you're aware that christchurch city
have undertaken quite a significant
upgrade at the equifax
modeling and if anybody's ever been on
their site it's
it's pretty impressive or very
interactive
system where you can plot in your own
land and predict the earthquake
and it will tell you what you could
expect and give you visual pictures of
that
amendment liquefaction etc our council
made a decision that we do not have
really a significant amount of raw data
that would better inform that
liquefaction decision that we had in
2013 there hasn't been
as much additional ground investigation
as it has been across uc
and so therefore we were of the view
that we could end up spending a hundred
thousand dollars and not really improve
the underlying basis of our modeling
very much at all in addition to that
the liquefaction is really what i can
show you here it's effectively only
you know two areas of the district
and it's not really hard and fast rules
that will apply in those two areas and
so
the the location of that line is less
critical
for developers or landowners than it
otherwise would have been if it had
been they'll shalt not build here and
they'll shoot the
new camden there it is much more along
the lines of
the perfection as possible on the side
of the line and therefore you need to do
some further work
to satisfy us and whereas the protection
is
unlikely on this side of the line
and the third point that the council
took into account is we didn't believe
this was likely to be an area
that would receive a significant
challenge from
uh from any of those who wish to submit
on the district plan
it's not a highly contentious point as
to where that line would be
and so therefore if all of those things
summed up we thought we'll just
state the 2013 plan
and go forward with our policy response
in that manner so it's only coming to
light here
in terms of what it is but as as you can
see it all that you will be able to see
short years
it's it's very it's no different really
then
than it was before effectively we've got
the green the green actually extends for
the rest of the district it's just that
was
the extent of the study area but
basically different faction damage is
unlikely
and the
and so then there will be obviously
rules
written into the district plan about
what that effectively means
for any person to build and develop
areas the flooding i think is the most
interesting to us and this effectively
is
where i was referring to before
first off when you click on that we get
the
hazard map which effectively relates to
the hazards
as defined in the regional policy
statement
so we have
high medium and low
hazard areas and you can see here that
we can
obviously search there's a search button
for searching on
specific properties
and we can go you know go in and out and
move around on the map to see
and to see in closer now as i
indicated this map is effectively
the combined outer edge
of the 200 year
flooding maps from the three different
sources that we talked about before and
if you're interested in hearing words
down here
and when we get down a little further
we can see here that we can click on the
three
individual flooding maps
which make up uh which feed into that
underlying hazard now
so for instance the 200-year localized
flood depth now this doesn't show in
terms of hazards
it's more shown in terms of peace
whereas you may be aware the hazard
is actually a combination of depth
and or velocity so high depth and low
velocity or high velocity and low gear
both potentially lead to high hazard
as such so you can see here with the
localized
flooding uh we obviously have a fair bit
of flooding in this area here rangiora
just slightly darker shaded here kyboy
sitting down in this area down in here
and you can see north of the motorcycle
there's a significant area but it also
extends beyond the motorway
so obviously from this perspective you
can
see that we do have quite an area
in this part of our district which is in
particular
affected by this and i think in fairness
it's fair to say that effectively what
we've got is know
basically a bathtub where this is a
lower ponding area
where the the water just effectively
comes down towards it and it builds up
in that particular area
what was the value
and again you can see effectively
here so the way this works is we
have you can have identified uh
about four or five sites where they
believe
it is more likely that the action will
break out
now of course the action may break out
anywhere along its length
but based on their probabilistic
scenarios
that i've identified and this one here
is one of those because it is
opposite the the river coming in
thank you the river coming in from the
north which places additional
stress here and i'd add there's a couple
of so much complications but things
so these these
potential breakouts again and you know
probably preaching the diverter with
some of these but just to remind us
scott banks or rivers can fail
for a couple of reasons two main reasons
one is that the stock bank's
over top and that is a capacity type
issue
and the other is that even less than
that specific capacity that you may
design for
they may have failed you to scour and
that's usually as the flows are actually
going down
after an event when they're already
saturated and there's quite a bit of
turmoil happening and so these
probabilities which have come out from
the ecan
uh and take into account both potential
factors in terms of the modelling
no natural waterways
so that water's still effectively
flowing it's just underground
so a couple of other points to note
about this firstly
previously there was quite a significant
additional breakout coming from here
down through this area here you'll feel
that
well we're again the secondary stop
banks are in place from that area there
and it was really uh very very pleasing
to see
from our own modeling uh that that
actually
indicated that that is sending the flow
back
into the river which is
good to have that added
certainty behind that the other thing
i'll note is
while you may again expect that this
model of flood breakout was mainly going
to be in the ashland area
again it's in this coastal area here
where effectively the old estuary came
all the way up through here
that is where the modelling shows
significant flooding from the national
breakout
and again for al-qaeda it's
the most tender stick again as well
this is going to be very good
information for the council the council
has received this information
in the purpose of doing that was to
ensure
that we could make available to the
public
and also make sure it's taken into
account in our
in our own workings we have not yet
turned our mind
to whether we believe for instance this
level of flooding from a stop bank
is acceptable or not and pass an opinion
onto weekend
and it may well be that as a result of
that further
thinking about this particular issue
that the council
decides that it does wish to make a
submission to the uk
to do something about these stopping
breakouts now obviously the thing they
they would do if they were of a mind to
accept that
is uh especially of course to a bit of
investigation and then
once they determined there was some work
to do that
the cost of that would be applied over
the appropriate rating banks and there
would be
a new conversation to be had
with through their long-term plan or
probably long-term plans just in your
bank
which then looked at establishing
an effective rate over that area to do
something about that
so those are all options for the council
to think about
one major issue that is of council's
minds of course is this
in this area here is the direction that
rangiora
is you know looking to grow and at the
moment
most of the development in that area we
are dealing with by asking people to
protect their own land from
this type of event it may well be
more prudent for the council to think
about a
a bigger abroad that the costs were
actually recovered
over a wider area with larger stop banks
and channels
further around still and those again are
decisions
for the council to think about and
another thing i need to think about of
course is our own assets
what does this level of flooding mean
for us in terms of the protection of our
own assets
we're already mindfully designed for
flood events as we're designing our
works
but it is potentially proven for us to
look back over our shoulder and see
what we have now that is possibly more
uh prone uh to the effects of this type
of
flooding than potentially we might have
thought in the past
so i think there will be a number of
streams of work
that fall out of this again this raw
data
so to speak as we go forward in the
future
if you're going to leave that was a
question
[Music]
do to stop this flooding so is the
district plan likely
to put a fault on development within
some of these areas
so the district sorry i can probably
answer
as well as
councillor stewart the district plan
will be placing a number of rules
on high medium and low it
may be that it does not take
quite such a different thou shalt not
it'll be more
you need to show us how you're getting
those effects
and all of that will take place well
before
you can even consider this issue and so
the council will be making decisions for
the next
10 years with the information we have
now if in over the next for instance
three years
this conversation advances and he came
here
to plan for this work the council
probably still would want to see that
work implemented
and being properly modeled before it was
prepared to change its underlying zone
uh
requirements anyway so we you know
without
being too concerned about this we could
well be talking about a 10-year
cycle even if we wanted to wait it
seemed like a cautionary principle but
that's correct and and there are and i'm
not going to speak to those policy
responses because there are
quite different approaches for for
instance uh what
again what the policy people are doing
is thinking about
the sensitivity of the activity to this
planning so it's not just
the hazard but the sensitivity of the
activity so for instance if you're going
on the garden chair
it may well be that it was was
acceptable and
what as well as a gunship what else
might be in that category so there's
lots of thinking about that
sensitivity when we get into the larger
three hundred and
two or three hundred lot subdivisions
there'll be a completely different
set of guidelines and rules in the world
before extensions to a house
for instance so again lots of thinking
that
councilman stewart and many others will
be thinking about as you get closer to
developing that district plan
i don't know
pushed through this committee for nine
years they thought that we should be
just developing around
nature those were one of the prime
examples of not trying to control the
transfer
we're not trying to control that to
actually work
remember the field trip we did when the
farmer spoke about the actually breakout
that would have gone
through back and forth and he was
concerned about the raising of those
that subdivision where the path of the
water would go in the future
so obviously you can get your own land
to protect your own space what do you do
to enable us well silverstream is a
classic example
that's going to tip all the water into
those other light bulbs
because that was the previous breakout
wasn't it
then you've got landing
i can say that for resource consent
applications
effect on enables is a critical issue
that is
thought about it's certainly not silent
it's quite a lot of work
the planners and the modelers and the
engineers
[Applause]
this is the last one in the flooding
that i just mentioned again you can see
here again it's largely obviously
the coastal area that is affected by
this one this is the coastal flood depth
uh and that as i say is the outer line
of effectively ten different scenarios
that we have modeled which do match what
christchurch has
done as well so there's a area of
alignment between the two
councils
stanley
[Laughter]
hold you up it's coastal erosion is the
one good news story we have in
this effectively what we are saying
is we have a lovely big source of
material just to the south of us which
caused thousands of cubic meters of
material into the sea every year called
the waimakariri river
and that all drifts north and
effectively the modeling is clearly
showing
that this resupply of material
outstrips the
the the seedling rise so
waimakariri district does not have
a coastal erosion issue apart from
potentially in the very north of our
district in the waikoko area
where that beneficial effect is starting
to wear off
by the time you get that far north but
we are seeing our shoreline
moving outwards that's not
showing it very clearly there but
effectively
if we look closely to that you will see
that the junior line is historically
moving out and will continue to do so
even with the seat of the rise
so coastal erosion will not be a
significant issue
for us that we need to deal with in the
district plan
and just quickly while i mentioned that
we didn't see a default rupture plan
if i just quickly show you things have
been updated
from ecan and
the university and others who have been
working on this information
over time but you can effectively see
that the majority of the
uh faults are uh
um
but you can see the one area that a
closer study actually has been done
uh this was done some time ago this is
the ocean area and as you can see we
have very closely
marked lines there because we do have a
lot better information about the
location of those faults
whereas once we get up into these areas
we think it's somewhere in there so
please stay well away that's really all
you can read a little bit widespread
here
and unless unless there was a real need
i don't
know if the council will be putting much
effort into trying to
better define those but it may be
something that an individual developer
would wish to develop
so that's probably about spinning
very informative
[Laughter]
stays available to everybody so they
have to get access
it's a very good question i clicked on
my youtube spot
of live uh consultation you can find it
wasn't there and it got me thinking well
i wonder how long it will stay in this
site so i will go back to um to the
council website owners and make sure
that even if it disappears from our
consultation sites it is still available
and it is easily findable in an obvious
site
is such a great resource aren't they
yeah
so i've got a recommendation that we
receive that natural hazards mapping
report
any further discussion there
i've approved
thank you item five which is the kaiko
river monitoring and management updates
mr meredith sir you have the chair
[Applause]
okay
as i see it in sort of putting together
a how you go about monitoring the
kaikohe river
um in that it's a large tidal water body
it receives a lot of complaints
and therefore it's generally a poor
water quality as an issue
but it's very complex flow dynamic area
and therefore we
really have to treat it more like a
labor and history
in a monitoring sense answer
with sort of various influences of
hearing flow contributions
you know we had to go into the sort of
15-minute
continuous monitoring type approach that
we often do in lakes
and therefore we have to we'd be putting
a series of different continuous
quality instruments in there um it's an
area we've been moving into from from a
late perspective a lot but haven't
really done
rivers to date although we are starting
to get into it from uh approach as well
which is another sort of area of
interest
so these these sort of areas we're sort
of scoping up at the moment
and only by sampling in this mannequin
the various degraded features of the
water quality of the pipe would rather
really be characterized and we can sort
of tease apart them
and figure out what could be done about
them once again
i've talked to you before about the
salinity sort of monitoring which has
been a test case
the most effective site for installing
this equipment the same as the salinity
was off the
mandible bridge because it flows through
a
has a very easily
has small bridge vials that are easy to
attach equipment to
and represents a very beneficial site in
the river as well
so really we're just working through
designs and mounting installation and
powering this
equipment so that we can get it in this
summer it's quite it's a little bit more
complicated than we first thought so
it's taking a while
i have put a presentation here together
on
a few more details
so
so really what i was going to cover with
this is why the high point of equality
is not routinely monitored
some of what some of the new drivers are
that that's why we would have needed to
get into this if we weren't
taking the initiative anyway some
learnings today current proposals
in many respects the quebec with the
answer which
council stewart was asking me earlier on
when is this going to be in
and if you will and i was going to
finish with some quick challenges of
how we measure flow as a relationship
related issue here
um so
previous legislation and to interpret
the interpretation of previous
legislation was that many controls are
not operative in tidal waterways
because they're really too dynamic too
complicated so we really don't have a
history of monitoring in those waterways
because we can get away with not doing
so
so there's very little randomized grab
sampling occurs in these tighter
waterways
or if it does the interpolation is
really difficult so therefore it's
absent from
tools like the lower website and things
like that
so in these environments we either need
to do stratified sampling and
either only going there at low tide or
only going there at high tide which is
really difficult for our field staff
who are having to sort of tie everything
else around that or the continuous
monitoring of the illustrators here
so such monitoring entitled always as
rare all they can
although these are highly valued in
environments like hypo river town which
is why we're talking about it today
new drivers you can have a presentation
shortly on the nps
national policy statement for fresh
water management i would just
rather than take away from that i'll
just put a few points here
the nps even gives stronger drive to
address some of these challenges in a
common area like the one that like the
kaiba river
not just the concept of tamannaah dwight
but policy three is saying the
freshwater is
it needs to be managed in an integrated
manner
section 3.5 recognizes integrated
meaning recognizing the connectedness of
the whole environment from mountains to
lakes
down to the rivers lagoons easter eggs
etc
and talks about receiving environments
and also at section 313 talks left
special provisions for accurate
affecting nutrients
and therefore talks about nutrient
sensitive downstream receiving
environments
and i would contend that many of the
problems
river through the middle of is it is a
nutrient sensitive receiving environment
so really the nutshell of that is not
expedient to ignore it
our learnings to date has been the
salinity work i've talked to you about
we picked off just one parameter
salinity it's helped us understand the
kaiba environment
considerably it's helped us identify the
challenges and the opportunities
working in the sierra area and so we've
learned a lot before launching into a
full
continuous monitoring site this
schematic on the lower right there is
sort of
showing that we've got four metres of
water playing with with
a two meter tidal movement so it's a
real challenge for me to position this
equipment
the other learnings are our lakes
approaches the left-hand side photo
is lake pearson which is where all our
effort has gone to very recently that's
a monitoring site that's just gone in
so it's anchored out in good water on a
buoy
the middle site is tawahara logalismia
and that's where
the monitor equipment is sighted off uh
piles off sort of small
metal piles from them into the lake bed
or the riverbed
and the far right hand side is river
they forsyth where it's where it's a
structure built off the side of the
water body
now we're probably probably not these
are all
issues where we've learned a lot from
and as i say this is why we're
using a bridge pile on the mandible
bridge as yet another
of this on light on lakes this is a
schematic from the lake pearson boy you
can see that quite a complex
set of equipment and so we're trying to
work through suitable equipment
different size
options power options security et cetera
et cetera
so the current proposal is to continue
development of the mandible bridge
and select more detector position
equipment parameters and telemetry
once again basically just working at
this site here
there's a whole series of parameters we
would measure there with continuous
monitoring network
and but there are some things we can't
measure so we're still going to have to
grab that grab samples for monthly
phytoplankton species
see what's actually growing and causing
the elder blooms in the river
and some monthly cave samples things
like phosphorus and other things that
we still do not have continuous
monitoring equipment for
and so really what it's going to look
like is a ysi
x03 or aquatrol sonde which is a piece
of equipment with about four or five
probes attached to it with two tossing
up between these two pieces of equipment
we thought we were going to use the aqua
troll we've had a couple of
failed recently so we may be going to
the slightly more expensive wire side we
want to do the right thing get the right
one in
they have different anti-fouling and
cleaning systems on them
and so that's a bit of a delay we've had
choosing which one
as of the trios nitrate logger we've
already purchased one that's
we've got that on on hand and it's a
saline suitable titanium version
with salinity correction hasn't been
used before in new zealand so we're
quite excited about
leading new zealand and sort of doing
nutrient type work in a
sideline environment the other thing we
need to do is design the mounting system
down
down the pile of the bridge here using
once again learnings from the lake
program but it has to be so
line corrosion resistant mounting
retrieval system
and secure equipment so both it survives
there for a decent period of time and
doesn't get stolen
and so our limitations to date i would
love to be telling you that the
equipment was entered in now or going in
next week but
as i said earlier we're recruiting a new
continuous monitoring technician
and now that the black pearson boy has
gone in this will be the next
program we hope and also there's a bit
of equipment availability with kobed19
importing equipment from overseas it's
taking a bit longer and slower than the
previous was
so we anticipate the design of this
station to be completed this summer but
i would anticipate probably not before
february
the future developments of this is
online data display so that we can have
it up on the website
and sort of get community involved in
this as well
and also looking for analysis of data
and development of models
so we can be ongoing with this so we can
do these predictions
of how management of the river should
change
and there's also a possible opportunity
here to transfer these learnings to
other
tidal water bodies particularly
downstream in the waimakariri river
when that comes up for sort of screwed
planting type scrutiny in the future
that should probably move into that area
and other canterbury tidal water bodies
like on the north and south end of
timaru as well
and so and saltwater creek is another
very obvious one that has a big tiny
period
and some understanding that the final
issue i'll touch and i've just zoomed
through this is riverflow and i think
councilman stewart was questioning this
in a previous meeting
it's really difficult to measure flow in
these tidal water bodies
to date we've summed the flows of all
the contributing catchments at their
minimum flow sites but with no
correction of what the additional water
yield might be down below those
the waimakariri river at old highway
bridge is assessed from brief
low flow periods in the hydrograph and
our
hydrologists are pretty good at that but
the whole the tide goes totally
out so that's reliable at the moment we
could do that just below the line side
road floodgates in the highway river
because there is a period of opportunity
there but below that
um the river is just sort of deep and
doesn't the tide doesn't go out and
leave a sort of low flow pattern
so we really can't correct for kang
river or the courtney stream
however i've been talking to mark
mcgorgan who did a lot of their
hydrology work
for the zipper and plant change seven
and he was modeling additional flow
yields
and that's probably more accurate than
trying to go through
um measurement systems in the lower high
point
but really what's the question i think a
relative flow from some tributary froze
should be adequate
in giving in assessing the relative
value of the
fresh water flows coming in and
correlating those with the water quality
and things like that so
it's a good conversation to have but i
think we've probably got that
sun i've talked about it to a number of
hydrologists both with the nikken
and aniwa and mike mcgorgon as well
so the conclusion is the continuous
water quality monitoring site in the
kaikoura river is necessary to
understand and manage these issues
it is achievable and should be up and
scored and up and running later this
summer
okay thank you
very welcome um how much data would you
imagine
that you would need over what period of
time before you could draw some
conclusions
about how once you've managed the
kind of world well we've been teasing
apart seasonality as well as that so
we will probably do an analysis after
the first year of data but we'll be
certainly only for at least a couple of
years before we'd be seeing clearer sort
of patterns
[Applause]
we're in the hands of the climate a
little bit as to what
sort of waimakariri river blows and
catchment clothes it gives us
particularly during the summer i think
can we have a copy of that
it's not in the agenda no i appreciate
that i think it's significant
thank you would you be happy as a
committee
um if i included
the presentation agreement just provided
with the minutes
so that it accompanies the unconfirmed
minutes of this meeting so you've got it
in the next meetings
but now that particularly wonderful okay
so circulate it afterward
thank you any further questions
adrian
thank you sir keep up good work
uh so we have i'm happy to move the
recommendations
thank you yes we've received
[Music]
thank you adrian it's the most
significant piece of
work i think we've had before us as far
as
this very degraded receiving environment
goes and
i am hopeful that you get all this fancy
gear in as soon as you can
and that within hopefully um
even by the end of 2021 we have some
uh information coming back i think
the wider population in kyoto would be
really appreciative
to know that finally we are going to get
some very relevant data
to set us on the path of being able to
manage this
and address the real degradation of the
service system
so thank you i think
you can't manage it unless you've
measured it but it's been a really
difficult place to try and figure out
how to measure it appropriately so
thank you thank you
any further discussion
so we will move that motion that we
accept that
all those in favor
[Applause]
package
[Music]
[Applause]
the um position of the presentation with
advanced
workstation what to take it is read and
open up the session
for discussion um i can
pull up the presentation for those in
the audience to have
a quick look at it
effectively this is a just to give you a
wee bit of background
[Music]
at their meeting so this presentation is
the same
one going to all of the water zone
committees
[Applause]
two people in the room that may be able
to contribute to the discussion
um that have been part of pulling this
uh together for all of the zoning
companies on behalf
but also um as we talked about at the
previous meeting
it's it's really um
by iteration that will collectively get
your heads around
the significance of the essential
freshwater package
and it will probably be over the next
couple of years that we've just
continuing to
sort of work through what it means for
this really from
regulatory point of view from the
territorial authority from
companies and obviously farmers and so
on so
really just uh i guess uh i can quickly
touch on the first
few slides or unless there's any
immediate questions about people
the question is just a detail because i
haven't
been through um stock exclusion from
white where was it
[Applause]
um the discussion on friday
at this answers
[Applause]
the plan for us to write action plans i
mean it's more
i mean not too many things now but we're
talking about having
action plans for the certain committees
[Music]
is
action
a slightly indirect effect
but it is worth noting that because it's
a nationwide pace of
regulation you look at it and sometimes
you look at it and you're like oh yeah
we've never done that
or quite that but
you just sometimes you look at it and
you're like why aren't people doing that
already
because
unfortunately it doesn't go any further
than that in terms of the credit
no yeah that's right because the at the
regional committee meeting they were
saying
you might be able to correct me
the nps is looking at costing um
about eight and 30 million dollars over
the next
five years in terms of working out
you know what we need to do with the
planning that we've got
what we need to do sort to change
it strikes me you know does the average
joe blogs in town and the towns and the
cities realise
where that money's gonna have to come
from and it's not actually gonna be
making any difference to our water
it's just money that has to be spent on
all the planning and administrative side
of it
i think this is really interesting
legislation before the stuff that hasn't
been through a select committee
uh you know it hasn't been through the
democratic process really i suppose
uh but the bottom line is that it was
really interesting because as soon as it
got gazetted on the 6th of august
basically became mandatory i suppose
then it was as soon as you had the third
september that's today
so which makes it really interesting
because what it does is this
new essential freshwater package sets
that up as the
while in the canterbury land original
plan we've set the baseline is
209 to 213 so i don't know how that's
going to work because other planet
change seven
which you can't really talk about
because it's before the process but
you know it's uh it has regard to it
anyway
it's heavy regarding this new
legislation so which is quite
interesting but i think the other thing
too is that now that we've
had the election that's all through
there's there's going to be ongoing
discussions about
how workforce some of these things are
and there'll be some change
um page 27 a new national bottom line
for ammonia
is it a rule of thumb that um you know
the
concentration of ammonia and any sort of
water sample of the tenth of the nitrate
level
um or so what's the relationship and
also is ecan monitoring for
ammonia
across the region that we we do by grab
something
um this change isn't going to make much
difference to us because the ammonia
levels are generally pretty low in
canterbury
um in terms of the in terms of the
second art question in terms of the
kaiboy river
no it would ammonia isn't something that
we'll be monitoring
continuous monitoring data because there
isn't
um particularly reliable probes that we
whether we'd
be using for that
that are available are not very reliable
and the concentrations are generally so
low that we probably
they wouldn't be generating useful
information for us but you'll do it with
growth though
or can we do it with great samples in
all the tributaries coming into the
cowboy
and we'll probably do it as grab samples
to give some reference as well
thank you
oh
yeah so particularly for drainage
obviously we have been looking at where
their overlapping network
and we've started with this wc staff as
a gold council to not
um have any works so about consent that
we've been applying for for a while to
join drainage mine works consent we've
decided to explode anything to the eps
that's new in that consent because it
would mean it would delay it for
another year or so we have to look at
how you know
there will be a different concept to
look at works within a weak land
as a council there is an exemption that
for specified infrastructure which can
be drains
but you have to also still get consent
so
it's prohibitive for everybody else to
do works like drainage weeks
except for people who or
entities that meet the specified
infrastructure
exemption and we will need to
get a consent and you have to meet
conditions such as not changing the bed
of the drain for 30 days so you're not
supposed to deepen
the drains and change the hydrology so
it's a bit of an interesting one about
how you can still do drainage
so meet those conditions so we suggested
we're also
looking for guidance between ep and ecan
and it's going to take a while to
interpret uh it seems like the focus is
beyond the farming community what the
impacts
like and so they're raising trying to
get guidance there will be switching
that space and for our council and
spiritual authorities it's going to be
a bit of a thing to still be playing out
for a while
instructed
um i mean just highlighting that
hierarchy of obligations and
significance again another thing that
everyone
across the country this is working
through is is
angus guiding me to at that key point at
the bottom of the
sony object it is a hierarchy with it
the first order is
the product promise even to be addressed
while being awarded so um
i guess that is a a key point to be
aware of
um it's touched on a couple songs on the
slide but just something
to give emphasis too
and yeah and that's what it's sophie's
retreated with
remembering that it applies to all
activities that's subdivisions that's
drainage that's in humans in town as
well as
so it's pretty significant in terms of
the impact of development in general
in terms of the need to satisfy the
health of the environment first
yes related to that i'm guessing is
working through
applies
and receive updates
um i suspect
in terms of how we make sense of this
has why am i clearly still doing any
economic modelling
i just don't know there's some other tas
that has started so
you're always just wondering yeah okay
i'm interested to know yeah
you know which one and she wouldn't have
started that i'm not going to
lose something only donating to the
first
first cut impact rather than maybe knock
on effect into town and that's what that
but yeah
that started
yeah but our players definitely have
been interested in the wheatland
modeling for example with our district
plan
of residential urban boundaries
they call the community areas the areas
that
are currently not sown
that will become urban areas
constraints
yeah a good snapshot for now murray just
in terms of updates
on a beast now this needs to be
concerned
um but beyond that it's more of a
rolling wall
if you get to 2024 and the plans need to
be in place
and there's other deadlines in
so the time frames are still very short
even for us
as you can see we're a little ahead of
the game in some areas but the more we
look at it i guess in some ways the
harder it is
so and the other thing is there's a lot
of
top down as well waiting on muv
to give us direction there's a lot of
discussion amongst the regional councils
to try and get some synergies in terms
of the way we're receiving the
information
uh interpreting it and then digesting it
and getting it out again
and that takes a lot of effort so
and of course what this is going through
and how
the hearing commissioner is going to
treat this i certainly have to
um have to take it into account
how that pans out in the air
we will have to see so a lot happening
it's moving all the time if i can just
pick up one of those comments around the
consensus
at the moment they haven't done this
having an impact i can see
him so if you're here around the tracks
that someone's only got it or you can
see
um
until we receive any further advice
around the longer term um
so that you're reading this conversation
is the life
but that's where we're at in terms of
the level of uncertainties of countless
advice so
it's affecting them could you clarify
that with the idiot for example the
abuse
all the concepts that come in from now
incorporated the regional policy
right can i have a mover and a second to
please that we receive this update
for its information and with
consideration to its priorities
and community engagement and the
community engagement's
quite key piece too that we we as a
zone committee can hopefully facilitate
going forward
sorry digress dude thank you second
earth
john thank you
do we have any further discussion there
oh all those in favor
against carrick thank you
all right you're still in the chair
aren't you
yes that's handy could you move on to
item seven please
which seems just about longer than item
six
but uh let's see updates there is a lot
of content here i will um
i'll pass the ball periodically as we go
through the updates
because this is appropriate um
a proposed paint change seven is
um a regular update as you know i'm just
including it just so that if anyone is
referring to these papers that they can
get the most
recent information the one thing perhaps
to highlight to you is that i've
included
the bottom line that the hearings are
being recorded and are available
to view on the very own youtube channel
so you can
click on that link it will take you to
that channel where all of the
presentations are available to watch so
but that's just a
at the previous meeting so um
that's probably the only other that just
i guess what we touched on in the
workshop too just from talking to
amber crowley from the groundwater
science team as well
and she's talked through just in terms
of reports that
um will be on that website as the the
hearings goes through and into the new
year
and particularly the science team's
reported reply
which is a response to the
information presented through the
hearing that report will be
completed i think by february
next year so um that will become
available as it becomes publicly
available
on that website or make copies of our
community but you'll also
be talked about um some guidance says
to the the key reports that have been
provided through the hearing from the
science team so
we'll have that february march and next
year
[Applause]
if there's anything
the else
if not i can probably pass
the ball or the over in terms of cws
regional committee
um caroline has provided uh
his usual report 7.1
from the 13th october meeting so
carolina if you want to add anything or
if there's any questions
whether german arapata had seen the
ending progress on that front
and i understand that we are looking to
engage with
even first up and we're putting together
a
planner coming your way
um so
staff would report it back some of the
feedback
can i um the question around the
representation that's proposed for the
regional
committee to the iran city territorial
authority councils
yeah i just want to know the rationale
for that but i mean at the moment it
could be
the tas i mean as long as each committee
can appoint somebody who is in the
position to
take that role there might be a ta
representative involved
is that there's a change which
deliberately says no is there a reason
mario do you want to comment on that um
i'll let you because i don't know um so
some of it is around in it feel free to
chip in
as well carolyn um the idea with the
regional committee
changes is around getting a bit more of
a
smaller and more um finesse if you like
um committee and so that was it was one
of the
ones that popped out um
i think yeah it's just i mean
giving it him rewind a chance to talk
about these issues
you know i think it is a value 40 years
ago
and he came here
this has been very repetitive and
ongoing discussions around lots of
different
you know the components of what's in and
what's out and all those kinds of things
but it's been a pretty
long process uh as both council and
stuff we're working through
you know what does it look like in the
future
it's what we've got to at the moment
the regional community itself was
generally quite critical
but um
yes so and there's another part of the
discussion
as around where there is a favorite
length in there in terms of
um
but yeah in terms of it being tied up in
terms of committee structure
as far as i'm aware there's something
that's sit in the cwm messages
yes
[Music]
um but i can
probably
report that's included
from the landlord committee is it
i've got one small question with regard
to the token
report to have sort of a
an upstream starting point and a
downstream starting point in terms of
the area it was covering
well the highest river rehabilitation
project had a
boundary i'm guessing that that's but i
think they're told specifically those
three projects you want
and then i think it was
joseph thomas that changed
[Applause]
i wanted to make was just to draw your
attention to
recommendation e in that report on page
2 of 10
which the landlord committee
unanimously supported which
action
[Applause]
um for your attendance
we just need to slow it down and have
one person talking in time because
he has only got one hands right
so do we want to wind it back
a couple of steps just so we can record
that conversation in a minute
there is no fish in the river at the
moment so everyone's losing out
john you had your hand up you're very
polite
sort of um the
construction of gravity on the elbow is
[Music]
all right thank you very much
the next item's committee's working
group
and um caroline and juvederm
and canva victor provide just a short
update
for each of those
no we were just waiting for um further
conversation with the landcare trust
and just seeing where they're at with
some
internal work okay yeah that's good
thank you
there was also the working group that
the
next generation farmers that are going
to be playing quite a big part to
landcare
okay um just that
following the discussions we had in our
workshop today
um the uh biodiversity working group
is next meeting
discussion about options for something
broadly called a community biodiversity
trust for the district
um
um just the date of our next meeting is
this
of november um we're also having a um
field trip to the lauren road and
strangers road areas
um that's great thank you thanks are
there any other questions groups
communications and engagement i'll
refer to angus remember the one thing we
did include
given that site visit
some of the committee here with uh
macarooni we just included that in a
handy client
info sheet it's been developed just as a
useful reference for that
developing piece of work and um
so yeah so it was time to put that in um
[Applause]
is we picked up a very good pamphlet on
wetlands it's been
developed in kaikoura and we are looking
to do something specific for this zone
and also
for uranus as well
and hopefully that will be useful
there's a handout
on the web website etc so sephora and a
couple of others are
working on that there's a man jumping up
and down
that's actually going to be part of a
graduate program called guardians
which is actually about making the
landowners the euro by doing the right
thing
so it's that that happens to be a subset
of the middle
and uh you'll probably not be in the new
year but we'll present these large
sort of signature group programs so you
can see how everything kind of
links together
the more i hear about wetlands the
happier i am
um a couple of weeks ago and there's
another reason
can didn't talk about the cardboard ruby
yesterday but whilst i
probably had to go down there once every
12 18 months what had been amazing was
actually the flow
just with the tigers coming in when we
talked about the kite
rivers we're going down there just to
see how fast that is
coming in so doing the issues talk about
dealing with you
understand that volume but the other
part is to do with the bike track that's
the venture bike track which we're
looking at putting in
through the round but people in the
community wanted to put it through the
wetland
because that land is just stuffed and
it's kind of like pulling out there's
the wetlands and the valleys however if
you want to see
the transition of a wetland from one of
those places
it's actually pretty amazing to see
what's happening down there the
transitions going through
the old willow's dialing off everything
else coming back from the scale of it
so at some stage we're meeting here one
day i suggest we go for a walk
and never ever
andrew at the workshop earlier sorry
that afternoon we did talk
i didn't raise the fact that you had a
that site is an option for
just in the meeting
thank you anytime a bit of debate about
whether
it's post earthquake or post lowering
the
uh
for debate of course
moving on to the next item which is on
the lower
website which was obviously expression
point from the previous
two meetings and um
i don't know whether seeing the clock
there in the time i don't know whether
you want to bring it
because tim dave did throw a
presentation together but you probably
don't want another one at the stage
is
website is upgraded every 12 months
so on the 30th of september a report
came out summarizing all the trends
that have been updated in new zealand
including canterbury
and that that was illustrated from data
that was that was updated to the 30th of
june the lower
the lower website is now it did explain
data up to 30
during this year so that's something and
one of the problems you asked for was
why waimakariri old highway bridge
hadn't been on the website
and we've been digging into a reason for
that it's now
on the website we did some very rapid
sort of
peddling to try to make sure it was
there the problem with that is though
waimakariri sites
national rivers network so we don't
contribute the data neewo does that
and there are some glitches in that
subsequent to that given that we're and
we're now paying for most of that new
work data to be collected and things
like that and taking it over
we'll take ownership of that in the
future so that shouldn't be a problem so
that
particularly those important river sites
like the waimakariri and the two sites
on that
there shouldn't be a glitch in the
problem because they'll be bundled
together with all the year
also we apologize for where that was at
um there were also a number of questions
that you that were raised at the last
meeting and i apologized i wasn't here
for
ill health
totally acknowledged that the lava
cycles to go up a number of years ago
before
it was viewers of a action point sort of
trying to update
and clarifying that so we're trying to
make sure that those
those naming regimes are correct along
the way from here on
because i think for the same reason that
you wanted to change it
makes it very much clearer so you've got
in the silver stream where you
measure road will go on through the
silver stream
and where you measure out here
and we'll get something at some point
about
as you get a data and well my question
is for so silverstream and other
tributaries
is where do we look at um
and can can measure that you know the
analysis of exactly what is collected
at these various monitoring points
and what we need as far as mps goes and
just
general water quality data
well the presentation that other um
tinder put together was illustrating how
the
you know our advice to just about
everyone is to
first use the lower website because it
makes data available in a standardised
manner
and they should start there any requests
beyond that should come back to weekend
it's almost an answer to cam's question
at the last meeting is that the lower
website isn't
zonally orientated it's catchment or
regionally orientated
and and it does that very well but not
now
kirsty and our water data team has been
beavering away and hopefully in the next
couple of months she'll finally have
some
data zonal data reports coming out which
is a way of reporting this information
to zone committees like yourselves
along the commit lines of what you're
asking so therefore reporting against in
psfm eps etc like that
in a zonal sense because it's
unreasonable to expect
lava to sort of start changing its uh
its systems
for how we manage our data systems
and so therefore we're going to be
working in that direction
and i'll just make sure that um when
that becomes available we'll be
reporting it to you pretty much straight
away
cool i'm pleased adrian's mentioned that
because i
follow
and was given a little insight into
what's coming in terms of the
development so out of the
environment categories you may be aware
is have a dedicated team looking at
water data
for over the last 12 months at least
to kind of get on top of some of these
these bigger
data management issues around water and
so kirstie and colleagues are looking at
then how to
present that to the world in a
an engaging format from a higher level
kind of and she gave me an example of
the year plan and how that
to the public and then going through
into increasing technical right
through the technical reports and
commitments so i i think
you and and other zones are going to be
pleasantly
not surprised but um that they have i've
been getting on top of a lot of data and
working out how to present it uh in a
variety of levels
and that should be available sort of in
the first quarter of next year so
so i was i was really quite enthused
from my sort of
incidental query on behalf of you as a
committee to then see
what's coming yes but i would also say
that that will complement you know
they have a compliment rather than
replace it
really pleased with all the different
making data increasingly available to
people yeah but following on from
dave ashby's comment earlier about
trying to get especially more urban
people engaged in this process if they
can go to one place
and see the water quality in their
backyard
that's a good start and makes it easy
for them to get engaged
thank you
um folks i'll move on quickly again just
following
i guess the action points that adrian
hasn't addressed there he's touched on
like most of them and andrew is
still here but in the back of the room
but he's provided
um this was just the follow-up andrew to
the vegetation clearance in nashua gorge
and would be done as part of it
river protection and firewall management
project and you've provided a response
to the paper site
rather than actually remember i don't
know right yeah
i don't know if there's any questions
relative to what andrew's provided
[Applause]
with regards to the request
for an idea of future immediate steps
projects um
in all what they could at the next
meeting support
that um just because she's working
through and getting the next projects
available so it would obviously make
sense to present that as a
sort of in terms of what's looking
likely based on the next application so
there weren't any really at this for
this meeting but i think she will have
at least one for the december
team so she will include that kind of
poor production that she can when she
presents these applications
so i think that's svana thank you murray
any further questions for murray's
comprehensive
committee updates from 0.1 to 7.7
i have and a second please
thank you caroline thank you
any further discussion there
thank you item
eight confirmation of the minutes
[Applause]
do we have any questions from the
previous meeting
[Applause]
i probably should put my hand up to
apologize to the committee because i
think i probably
rushed through one motion and that was
the
uh ims motion i'm not sure if we had a
full enough discussion just picking up
on some emails i don't know
if anybody wanted to add to that at all
we are all relatively happy
okay
right could i have a move and a second
to please
that that those minutes are a true and
accurate record
no
any further discussion of those minutes
all those in favor against
carrot thanks folks
um that was a bit of a marathon
well there's a wee bit of general
business and they yeah we're nearly
there
general business
murray hi everyone um
no no just i just to bring through
this attention as your facilitator i got
summoned into a piece of work this
morning which
meant i got an update on the zone
committee review
that i previously hadn't seen
in which it confirms that um uh
one of the outstanding items to be
resolved as we move through this
process is confirming whether the kosher
city council
will have membership on the imac
priorities
discussion point i think given that we
hadn't noted there is something
formally on the table for this committee
and for one acquisition council to
consider overlapping just to
let you know that it is something to be
worked through
through this review process so i will
[Music]
i've got nothing more to add other than
it's
an idea and a some thing that has been
expressed
and would you like to hear the
um
yep
it is going to be a fixed issue
obviously through the kj7 process it's
takes
a significant interest uh in terms of
them being a stakeholder for what
happens in this site um
considering having
up to five council representatives
a very different scale of representation
is that what they have asked for
i think if we compare the involvement
some of the tears we've had in
um zone committees as we've talked about
before one movie
have really taken up the challenge and
been involved in allocated funds and
talking cape working really well and i
think it's really good we haven't seen
it will buy them from christchurch city
in the past
so if these kinds of conversations are
an indicator that they may
feed more violent in the future in terms
of what their involvement
in the cwms looks like i think that's a
good thing but what that looks like in
terms of the detail
is that christchurch city council is
sitting on this
committee or a community
well why don't i when i forward the
email to you i'll copy it to everyone
basically the review will be the
dictator as to what happens
but i think the council needs to
suggesting is
the intention of the viewers to give
feedback
[Music]
to get feedback from the committee and
also if you want to make registered
counseling in terms of
views on that so yeah and as i said
before
the information that
has been collated at the moment in terms
of zone
and regional committee reviews that
that will be coming back to council very
shortly so any
feedback in a timely fashion would be
helpful
would be a large contribution to our
immediate steps program if they joined
the table
yes they'd be expected to attend the
planting days around this oh i'm looking
for a dollar figure
you can actually putting it to
wbc because i haven't heard anything i
and i
not that i'm aware of um and that's a
question that
i have in my mind as well i only
underwear and they're working on it on
thursday and so intentions to catch up
with the camera
tomorrow um come out and see
what the next steps were for that
because my understanding was that it was
tied up with
the uh conversations with the original
committee as well and that
was what someone was born over there
well so i'm here to take a miniva the
papers my understanding is that the
decisions for
the code of conduct and the regional
committee are coming back to us
that's december councilman how come
so i mean if you want feedback
officially from wwdc something needs to
go through
that's yes so we can naturally do that
but there was no item on the original
okay that was just something as i said
i've been
somewhat absent or adjacent to some of
these conversations in the last little
while
um but claire has been aware of it um
has been advocating for him
so yeah so apology that didn't come to
you before then i wasn't sure whether or
not
what the process was for that before
today so i'm glad that morris brought it
up we've had this conversation and then
we can go from there
we'll get a chat well if you cast too
someone needs to put something
formally saying yeah
tomorrow
report about a year ago and it was just
a comment and
passing made by the christchurch city
council yes it was
membership but there was no discussion
on it we didn't discuss it
it was just it appears that someone's
put a form under them
because it's across the board that
they're wanting to be involved in
things in a way that we haven't seen
before
folks
the train continues
it's good to finish on a high
um
we haven't found any legal
so we launched you know senior until he
launched he claimed back in
august 17th august 86 um
um
[Music]
any other business ladies and gentlemen
no
our part if you could give us a carrot
here to send us on our way safely
thank you the next meeting folks is on
the 7th of december
as murray mentioned
you